[Música]
un dragón de tierra y piedra de casi 21
kilómetros serpentea por la campiña de
china con una historia casi tan larga
como su estructura
la Gran Muralla comenzó siendo varios
muros de tierra construido por los
estados feudales individuales durante el
periodo como protección contra Los
Invasores el emperador Tim She wong
unificó los estados en el año 221 antes
de Cristo y el Tíbet y el océano
Pacífico se convirtieron en barreras
pero las montañas seguían siendo
vulnerables a invasiones mongolas turcas
y de los
para defenderse de ellos El emperador
amplió los muros construidos por sus
predecesores conectando algunos y
fortaleciendo otros las estructuras
crecieron del in Tao en el oeste hacia
León dung en el este y colectivamente se
conocieron como la muralla larga para
realizar esta tarea el emperador reclutó
soldados y Plebeyos no siempre
voluntariamente de los miles de
constructores registrados durante la
dinastía chin muchos campesinos Fueron
reclutados por la fuerza y otros eran
criminales que cumplían sentencias bajo
la dinastía han La muralla se hizo aún
más larga y llegó a casi 6000 kilómetros
desde duing hasta el mar de Wall el
trabajo forzado continuó bajo el
emperador hangulli y la reputación de la
Muralla se convirtió en un conocido
lugar de sufrimiento
poemas y leyendas de la época hablaban
de obreros sepultados en fosas comunes o
incluso en la propia muralla Y si bien
no hay restos humanos encontrados en el
interior las fosas nos indican que
muchos trabajadores murieron por
accidentes hambre y agotamiento la
muralla era formidable pero no
invencible tanto que engies y su hijo
kublakan lograron superar la muralla
durante la invasión de los mongoles en
el siglo 13 después de que la dinastía
ming ganara el control en 1.368
comenzaron a refortificar y consolidar
más la muralla con ladrillos y piedras
de los hornos locales los casi nueve mil
kilómetros de paredes con un promedio de
siete metros de alto y seis punto cuatro
de ancho contaban con Torres de
vigilancia cuando se avistaban
asaltantes se emitían señales de fuego y
humo entre Torres hasta que llegaran los
refuerzos algunas aberturas en la
muralla les permitían a los arqueros
disparar contra Los invasores y desde
otras se lanzaban piedras pero la nueva
muralla no era suficiente
en 1644 los clanes manchu del Norte
derrocaron a los mink y establecieron la
dinastía cheng y anexaron a mongolia de
esta forma china era gobernada por los
mismos que Habían intentado impedir la
invasión con las fronteras del imperio
ampliadas Más allá de la Gran Muralla
las fortificaciones Perdieron su
propósito y sin refuerzo regular la
muralla empezó a estar en mal estado y
los ladrillos y piedras fueron saqueados
pero su función no había terminado
durante la Segunda Guerra Mundial China
la utilizó como defensa contra los
japoneses y se dice que algunas partes
se siguen utilizando para entrenamiento
militar pero el propósito principal
actual es cultural por ser una de las
mayores estructuras hechas por el hombre
se la denominó patrimonio de la
humanidad en 1987
originalmente construida para mantener a
la gente fuera de China la Gran Muralla
ahora recibe a millones de visitantes la
afluencia de tu ha causado que se
deteriore lo que llevó al gobierno a
impulsar iniciativas de conservación
también se aclama como única estructura
visible por el hombre desde el espacio
Pero eso no es del todo cierto en la
órbita baja de la tierra todo tipo de
estructuras como puentes carreteras y
aeropuertos son visibles y la Gran
Muralla apenas es perceptible desde la
luna no tiene ninguna chance pero es
desde la tierra que debemos seguir
estudiandola ya que todavía se descubren
nuevas secciones cada que se ramifican
desde el cuerpo principal y amplían este
extraordinario monumento al logro humano
de que signo es en el Zodiaco chino es
el animal asignado a su año de
nacimiento y todo comenzó con un
concurso conocido como La gran carrera
descubra los orígenes del zodiaco chino
con este video
[Música]